welcome to this video playing and
western international master em western
I have zero out of two against the sky
and I have pretty I have a vague
recollection that this wasn't like I
lost a very clear game but on time or
something somehow I have a bad memory
connected with this name okay I've
forgot to go to death be three be three
years and more interesting here okay so
let's um let's see got a catalan type of
position John maybe whoopsie eight now
Quinn b6 is always an idea for black
check I'm trying to maybe get some play
against the b5 porn I i played Quincy to
to quickly queen bee three years more
interesting because it keeps some
pressure against the b5 pond and now I'm
I don't have anything against the spawn
at all I mean I mean I have I can try
queen bee three and stuff but it's not
not convincing okay that's a bit
surprising maybe he can play with Bishop
c5 what really wow
check this looks this looks terrible
check how does he develop now when I the
knight on c6 and the night on a force
completely killing as a development I me
okay maybe maybe that's enough exchanged
already so that it's not losing straight
away but it looks Wow doesn't look good
the thing is he cannot move to this
happen I dropped yet checkmate and he
cannot move the bishop somewhere I can
go to e7 but this still is not allowing
castles and this one really i thought
Knight b6 would be something
hmm
Knight b6 maybe not 96
maybe I can just go here night one night
c5 okay come play 796 and if he goes for
that I can also just the tech with
Bishop f4
you're not sure if this was the best way
to go hmm the CF night f5 don't tell me
I'm losing him night f5 looked so no
maybe I can still play rugby said laughs
while I playing really shaky stuff at
the moment in this position to get
myself into some kind of trouble is
really amazing and I think it's still ok
I moved you soon but it's pure luck that
this is not losing straight away maybe
yeah maybe even Bishop e3 was what
wasn't the best and I need to do that
Jack I need to go here probably to not
run into checks and Bishop c5 rook the
aid maybe at the end it turns out that
this is even ok but it wasn't planned at
all and it still looks very shaky this
position I can maybe just drop the night
back on something then I give this check
now now I probably give the check check
and yeah I'd say he's in a pin but I'm
not seeing a great way forward could go
to d7 but it is really doing something I
don't know they are probably better than
retreating maybe 2 D 3 m's could have
been an idea to act to be honest just
attacking the beep oh yeah could have
been an idea certainly ok what does this
idea maybe 93 d1 something like that
but you cannot go to d 1 9 f8 and Roop
takes the one so I cannot go there
hmm still difficult to maybe just night
c5a come on let's see if I the ticket
him attack be three
yeah I was just thinking about this some
wacky counter-attack with age five this
is maybe puzzle G for a chain sh5
unbelievable
I can't believe it and really and this
is dangerous really dangerous
unbelievable unbelievable stuff I don't
see I don't see how I can prevent that
g4 h5 amazing yeah i need you i need to
exchange everything off here its own
evade everything else is h 5 g find a
probably lost unbelievable
really really stunning g4 it's not a
medium maybe we jack maybe with kingi
successor made bishop a six mid we've
got to 97 maybe i can somehow save
myself with some checks it's no 92 us
know me I'm morning it sucked swung it
suits on check check okay McGraw arms to
draw draw Alfred game time ok I mean not
winning is heartbreaking but I was
really thinking I could take lose it I
mean look like a completely toast here
complete toast okay let's now check how
I could have won this and this is bad I
mean maybe not but it just allowing all
this stuff is completely crazy he's just
we cannot move in this position I can
just play a good prophylactic move and
tiki has no way to get out of this it's
just plus two okay so I went into this
stuff and it's probably still winning
yeah maybe it's better to go to g1 now
but it feels we had to do so
check yeah I mean this is also also just
good around around here they're they're
probably ways to improve this check came
the computer here f4 f4 + 2.5 this is a
lot yeah probably there is no mood for
black
yeah I prevents also G hive and stuff
threatening eform yeah yeah well there
are many ways probably to win this this
is so this is not bad or anything but
around here that now suddenly this
counter play was coming this was
shocking g5 and aged 5 and therefore of
course 95 was yeah the constant gives
roop t7s very good but i needed to to
make to get out of the mate and around
here i'm not sure at all that there may
be was something h5 is no good okay
check check here King g5 is better or at
least clearer around here i will this
age for ya okay i'm sure i'm always
drawing with 95 but this was a close
call wow wow well not winning as i
mentioned is it's a bad thing but at
least I didn't lose at the end alright
thanks for watching